if you thought Mike Pence's campaign
announcement in Iowa yesterday was bad
just wait until you get a look at his
CNN Town Hall which was hosted by Dana
Bash you know one of the things that is
very interesting to see with these
modern right-wingers is how quickly
their talking points fall apart not when
presented with opposition per se from
the other side but simply when there is
any follow-up and Dana Bash as you will
see during some of these clips provides
just really simple questions that Mike
Pence at some point doesn't even know
how to respond to now to his credit I
will say Pence is starting to draw some
distinction with Donald Trump and you
you've got to do that if you're going to
justify people voting for you instead of
trump when you served under Trump why
would they go for the number two if they
like the number one when number one is
running okay you understand that here is
Pence saying Trump thinks Putin's a
genius
I think Putin is a war criminal all
right at least it's a distinction
Donald Trump said in his CNN Town Hall
he was asked whether he wanted Ukraine
to win the war
and he would not say what message does
that send to Vladimir Putin
well and frankly When Vladimir Putin
rolled into Ukraine
the former president called him a genius
oh I know the difference between a
genius and a war criminal right and I
know who needs to win in the war in
Ukraine and it's the people fighting for
their freedom and fighting to restore
their National sovereignty in Ukraine
and America it's not our war
but freedom is our fight and we need to
give the people of Ukraine the ability
to fight and defend their food even the
Applause is milk toast like it's not
just the answers nobody seems to eat in
any way inspired by this but listen to
Pence's credit there are other people
running in this Republican primary who
aren't even willing to say that so
credit where credit is due even if it's
for pathetically small things now here
was a really interesting moment Dana
Bash seemed to visibly stump Mike Pence
when she pointed out you know
deterrent claiming that the death
penalty for shootings will be a
deterrent doesn't make sense when many
of the mass Shooters want to be killed
and Pence was visibly stumped by this a
very interesting moment quickly go back
to something you said about a Expediting
the processing of people who engage in
mass shootings a lot of people who are
mass shooters that go in with the
intention to die right so how would the
threat of execution be a deterrent
well I
I follow these stories as closely as you
do
and of course our years in the white
house we saw one tragedy after another
and and I know we hear that and we we
see evidence oftentimes in the aftermath
that they went in without regard to
whether they would survive right but I I
just believe in the deterrent of the law
ah and I believe perhaps if if we made
it clear I mean think about this the
Parkland shooter is going to spend the
rest of his life in jail true in Florida
and that's not Justice okay
he believes in the deterrent of law
but that passing stricter gun laws
wouldn't make a difference how is that
possible the death penalty would be a
deterrent even though as Dana Bash
correctly points out many of these
shooters plan to die they want to die
sometimes they take their own lives if
they aren't taken by by First Responders
so that's going to be a deterrent
but stricter gun laws won't be a
deterrent that doesn't really make any
sense it says incoherent as many of
these modern Republican positions uh
Mike Pence talked falsely
about how Democrats want abortion on
demand until the moment of birth which
of course isn't true when Dana Bash
points that out the Democrat party's
position is abortion On Demand with
taxpayer dollars all the way up to the
moment of birth says who and as we talk
about the possibility of a national
standards a 15-week standard which will
put America more in line with most of
the European Union
most of the European countries have
either a 12 to 15 week rule on abortion
our laws today are more in line with
China Iran and North Korea
and for my part if I have the great
privilege to serve as president of the
United States I'll I'll support the
cause of Life at every level
state level the local level with
taxpayer dollars and at the national
level and just the person you're running
against or you want to run against if
you get the nomination is President
Biden he says that codifying Roe versus
Wade is his position that means a right
to an abortion until the point of
viability not up until uh until birth
but and and Mike Pence smirking at being
told the truth about the widespread
position from Joe Biden on that issue on
the question of Trump's crimes Penn
seems to be going with yes Trump
committed crimes and attempted to
violate the constitution but we kind of
should just move on with no consequences
I think now more than ever we ought to
be fine in ways we could actually come
together and this kind of this kind of
action by the Department of Justice I
think would only fuel uh further
division in the country let me also say
I think it would also send a terrible
message to The Wider world
I mean we're the
we're the emblem of democracy we're the
symbol of Justice indeed really the
serious matter which has already
happened once in New York
of indicting a former president of the
United States sends a terrible message
to the world I hope the doj thinks
better of it and resolves these issues
without an indictment sir I just want to
clarify what you're saying is that if
they believe he committed a crime they
should not go forward with an indictment
do you just talked before about no by
the way anybody else noticing how Pence
does this weird thing where while Dana
Bash is talking to him he doesn't look
at her he just looks out into the middle
distance it's a very strange thing and
Pence does this to a lot of people
getting to the rule of law clear that no
one's above the law okay
but with regard to the unique
circumstances here
no one's above the law but but but okay
just a couple more of these uh Penn says
that he has no interest in uh pardoning
the individuals convicted for rioting on
January 6th the Constitution of the
United States sir on that Donald Trump
says he is quote inclined to Pardon many
members of the mob who attacked the
capitol on January 6. those people were
of course part of the same mob who built
Gallows and chanted about wanting to
hang you right would you consider
partying and pardoning any of them
you know on the day of January 6 I
issued a tweet
demanding that people leave the capitol
folks he tweeted and end the violence
and I said that those that failed to do
that should be prosecuted to the fullest
extent of the law right
and I continue to believe that today
we cannot ever allow what happened on
January 6 to happen again in the heart
of our democracy what about the stand by
the decisions and the due process of
court in our laws and uh I I have no
interest or no intention
pardoning those that that assaulted
police officers
vandalized our Capital all right now
understand that even there he's saying
he has no interest in pardoning those
who assaulted police officers or
vandalized the capital but if there are
people who were charged for other things
he doesn't seem to be ruling that out
although with Pence you never really
know what he means with his slippery
language and then lastly Pence refusing
to rule out pardoning Donald Trump if he
were to be elected president
[Applause]
of a crime
and your elected president would you
pardon him
well I I don't want to speak about
hypotheticals oh
I'm not sure I'm going to be elected
president of the United States I'm sure
that you're not but okay
Dana I'm going to decline to answer that
on the basis that I have absolutely no
path to the nomination whatsoever and I
don't even know why I'm really here so
on that basis I'm going to decline to
answer that question
but I believe we have a fighting chance
I really believe we do and if you are
and I I would hope again Dana you're
you're as uh persistent as ever
CNN is living up to its reputation
and look there are real issues see
American people are facing and rather
than talking about that I want to talk
about with them so he doesn't want to
answer that question so a disastrous
campaign launch for Mike Pence no path
to the nomination but could he end up
helping Trump in Trump's path to the
Republican nomination we'll talk about
that maybe tomorrow maybe on Monday
if you deal with anxiety or depression
you may have tried meditation exercise
diet changes therapy all of which are
important things to try there is also a
new treatment that we've been talking
about on the program for years which for
many people has been a game changer and
that is ketamine therapy the research
around ketamine therapy for anxiety and
depression looks very promising which is
why I'm thrilled about our new sponsor
mind Bloom mind Bloom is the leader in
at home ketamine therapy having safely
helped thousands of people with anxiety
and depression it's delivered to your
door it's done from the comfort of your
home and unlike traditional talk therapy
ketamine Works quickly and doesn't have
the unpleasant side effects of
traditional antidepressants in a study
of over 1200 mind Bloom clients 89
reported improve in their anxiety and
depression after just two sessions read
about the evidence for ketamine therapy
we've talked about it on the show it's
pretty remarkable stuff mind Bloom is
offering my audience a hundred dollars
off your first six session program
go to mindbloom.com Pacman use the code
Pacman the link is in the description